hi and welcome to this week's impromptu
you Android developer office hours I'm
here with Matt gone our brand new google
TV developer advocate for europe and the
friendly face of Nick butcher behind me
we weren't planning to do one this week
but there's so much stuff that's come
through from google i/o that we thought
we jump in here and let you come along
and ask questions if you have any on all
of those lovely things that were
launched from the Nexus Q the Nexus
several we can finally show you these we
used to have them down here I've been
away when you're asking questions like
that's doing now that would be on a
nexus 7 but now we can hold them out
probably right yes this is the answer to
your question so if you've got any
questions today feel free to jump in or
ask questions on the G+ thread I'm just
going to bring it up on our other screen
and if you want to jump in here also
asked on the G+ thread and I'll invite
you in to the live session hanging out
right now come ask us android def
questions or just chillin for the recent
announcement we do have the standard
dory as well the moderator sorry to
those outside needle I just need to pick
up the link for it and i'll post it in
the messaging threat as well this one
lots of tikkun olam there we go or if
you came to Google i/o I'd love to hear
your favorite bits things that you liked
I'm just moving to the Dory now in the
thread here is the moderator and if you
don't know what this is then you can
come in and ask what that is as well
because it's awesome it's not about it
might be looking at me out looks like a
panda the people in customers certainly
thought it was today's hangout how many
people responsible for the entertained
for a little one well we are actually we
snuck in the YouTube there as well
watch on youtube money what you know
moving about hello youtube youtube.com
slash yeah right moderator page and all
these things will come together sorry
for the total randomness of today's
broadcast but we just decided
interesting but we just do one today
just in case you have any questions so
we do have one question how long do the
Hangout choosing last and are you
planning also select two o'clock from
Elena might ah they're always an hour
from 2pm to 3 p.m. unless we have
technical issues which right now it
happens quite consistently because this
is an SD studio we're getting our studio
ready and that should make us far more
reliable team so familiar couple of
weeks time we should be quite reliable
at 2pm 23 p.m. gmt on wednesdays so we
have settle down on TBN mostly because
we're having this hangout in freedom
time zone 2 first off in there asia
pacific time zone to give their time
then do down here in London that's again
open west coast of America so to sit
down to a nice time eight hour gap
pattern but if that time doesn't work
view you've got feedback that you'd
rather do it you know outside of your
work hours or some other feedbacks and
let's no proper comment on them that the
cheapest post office and in the
moderator that you already have and let
us know when might be better for you if
it's not working and at the same time
I'm going to try and set the time on
this thing that's counting down the pipe
bomb to do I time there you go that's
the time we have right now at 25 plus
two is we're the London office I exactly
I don't near right yeah does this help
he's not to avert your first hack for
that thing my first time I the AVL soon
as you said well is now this is new
Android ATK a new accessory a bad night
it used to just be that arduino board
that look quite rough already but you
can hack some awesome accessories
together
into this entire product and on the
inside you have the more familiar adk
board and wiring stuff but this
beautiful thing also has NFC as his big
LED renounce it has a speaker it has
bluetooth music protons so you can use
because ur as a booty speaker this
capacitive sensors up here for
controlling the volume there's a color
sensor on the front so you can say i
want the screen to be whatever color a
little change i can try that internet
this is bound up to where i should
change the color festival to something
other than green because everything is
very sweet so let's just go for the red
screen to start with well we have minus
joining us live on the Hangout why don't
we just check out what our favorite nap
somewhere my OH hi fair Patrick so Matt
Howie and what is he like what apart
from the obvious ly blatant display of
glass and the most epic way to introduce
it yeah that was a good start yeah but
that was obviously good front and but
yeah I think for me it was the jellybean
announcement like the amount of effort
that's kind of gone into that in the UI
looks so smooth so silky to me the same
with a nexus 7 like seeing it displayed
on that really nice so I think me that
that was one of the main announcements
cool yeah ouh was my best thing about oh
yeah my best thing about my owns I can't
make anything any more I don't have to
hide my nexus 7 on the tube and it's a
perfect supervisor all that media
capabilities I can run jelly bean on my
galaxy nexus without anyone trying
estimated luck about that are we
straight and the Nexus tube when people
come around my house and like what's
that for I don't just have to tell them
it's his favorite woman no so yeah just
staring all you that so much stuff
called announced that I aren't
especially related to Android maybe it
was all the stuff stuff more now need to
even more awesome vocals so a long time
on office hours and after hours there's
always a cute of people coming ask for
very technical questions on angry if you
already Orioles no I think we I think it
was a design exit seven I've been really
excited about the direction Android like
design and having these lots of apps
have been taken for a while
but I think blows developments at hell
not implementing lot of these things
because they didn't see this in case
perhaps I think this is going to change
that in this device is hot and it's
gonna sell a bunch and so I think it's
time to worry about alleged position and
get your apps using fragments and museum
like most emails and get them all pieces
in scaling using other games so that's
why I'm really excited well actually all
right let's do this so quick demo so
here's the color sensor I say I'm here
that I wanted to pick up color and the
whole the Krishna Bruntlett now you're
not going to believe other the light is
true oh did you actually see that maybe
it is on the screen perfectly on the
screen of that as soon as mr. magic it's
great when it's in your house and mrs.
right i hope the color color sensor oh
yeah okay Maxie okay let's have a look
through all the different sets of
comments and see what we've got coming
in one quick one patrick has asked what
happens the podcast ah so I think we so
it's still keen on doing that I think
you did the first one is an experiment
to see what new interest was like but I
think basically Google i/o largely
everything kind of berry and prepares
you for that so yeah you didn't write
things function in turn that you
interested it and we cookie and the
regular thing yeah I think it's going to
be more likely to happen for the office
hours than it is for the app reviews and
the game reviews listen to far more
visual or they are fun so hopefully
you're interested in having a video
podcast at some of those things and also
time it let us know what you think my
son Nina burrito night he feels about
everyone rethought it but probably
happen just to stop old fair Malcolm hey
will the Google Drive collaboration API
plan for the future be compatible with
Android example of our collaboration
listener to a text good question as
usual unsurprisingly we can't comment on
future roadmap but a good idea I'll
definitely pass on to the dr team ah lee
will be oakley is about to roll out the
US
good night in the UK I don't know
anything about that fortunately I can't
come on tonight good question though ah
no audio podcast is not convenient and
Patrick hopefully we have to order
virtual but our studio and things become
slightly more automated what's the
easiest way to start with Android
developing is there a specific ide you
guys use yes the first of all the
easiest ways to get to
developer.android.com and from there you
can follow the links to our training we
have 101 class training as well to
really get you started and a whole lot a
really useful developer information we
also have the installation guide which
will lead you I believe that we believe
it either eclipse on until the day so
I'm gonna coach easier district so easy
years and it sees me the first one to
get the AET a date trilight accountable
I mean IntelliJ user I used to use a
bitch but one day a kid coach is
updating its taking so long but during
the update i installed IntelliJ main
fixes my apps and publish them into the
android market who will post up before I
kitchen finished updating and a drink
here every time Sandra market somebody
has spring so I certainly going for
IntelliJ it just seems so much easier
now it has the android developer tools
plugin by default it's just that it
supports CVS svn and get my default
loads of the clips only the basic
versions you have to go explore these
things I found it very easy to get up
and running they've also just added a
visual IE for creating a droid layouts
into IntelliJ and that's the idea
community edition so it is free at all
very cool bond stuff that towards the
eclipse again is people as well yes over
the Eclipse is the one that's kind of
officially supported by our tools too if
you didn't catch it knows an excellent
section last week last Thursday morning
and what's new in Android tools with
haven't all amazing team people
baseballs and so yellow demonstrated and
it's on the latest stuff which I was in
WEP and some stuff that's coming so if
you haven't seen how i highly recommend
checking out yeah there are some of the
tools at the bar link yet although I
like more and more than
come online based on the loop guys catch
up very quickly overly fathia idea
intellij guys catch up for jamming in
the comment asks how about appcompat
library any ETA to be saved by appcompat
are you talking about the
actionbarcompat that Adam Powell
announce if so then knowing that we give
EJ's to release but so that's what you
need them but either way with every give
ETA 10 presence well let's invite
Shannon I don't clear who jump on and we
can talk about the library narrating
whatever it may be anyone else who wants
to jump in as well live on the session
in just ping in the Google+ comments and
or add you on so you can come in and ask
your question my life okay but one more
hmm alright although with Patrick first
I put it in the moderator hex compressed
xfer moderator my widgets stop
interacting with my application one of
the buttons is really simple it has a
pending intent to start the applications
main activity what could stop a pending
you take from working and how can we get
logcat info on the pending intent so
I've never seen this actually during
production of an application I've only
seen it during development if you're
developing a widget based application
and you add the widget to your home
screen and then you push a new version
of the application onto the device then
it's possible that it won't launch on
the intent because things do get a bit
out of sync you have to remove the
widget and it again but I certainly he
never once the application is fine life
first and I tried with your production
keys and put into the Play Store I've
never experienced that so if you have
any more details on it on the issue
please put them in and we can look into
it in more detail for you that's Patrick
Julia I have to run as well just in case
you so much' questions are coming in
saying when it's X being released and
just to reiterate as I said that some of
this it's a let's hang out you know we
hit store Android Elliman and you know
what's going on and will generally book
we're not here to make any product
announcements so we're not going to give
you any you know information on release
staff and we're not definitely going to
talk about blue states that haven't been
announced and so on and so forth so you
can ask such questions but we won't
answer yeah this is all about developers
asking sorry hope for example questions
nations in general about we are seven
changes and if we tell you one thing
you're probably long week you may as
well just wait sorry so yeah exit 17 18
I went then you've got a Potter
available would be lines so they will
see the in the section i 0 which
previewed it up on top which is
developed 30 odds evident exciting Oh
what is the timer what should I art
alright the time I think at the front of
people are just joined isn't one it's
the brand new accessory development kit
so hopefully it will be available by
accessory store android com in the
not-too-distant future if not already it
was given out to people at Google i/o
who attended the adk talk and it comes
to the product that you can use as a
bluetooth music player and clock and
other things and you can't roll if I
your phone by us via bluetooth but it is
to an hour and Android developers to
build accessories it's on the inside
it's got all the normal ATK stuff and
stop touch sensors on the topics of NFC
stop these display on the front the
bluetooth speaker and then the full ad
k2 board which now has an ftp nice one
here tonight bloomer baseboard so you
can control it when you're prototyping
your accessories and I hopefully do
rapid accessory development for android
and it's kind of cool so the things a
lot of people may have only got the ATK
one was a little remote control android
robot that was very easy it came with a
bunch of motifs and relays and things
like that would yet to see what people
build with the new capabilities of the
ATK to absolute item pull it up so since
we have met in the room as well much
will put it on the spot and ask if
there's any ah think from google i/o
that Google TV yeah now it's a cool
couple of things so the main one that
kind of launched the beta for YouTube
player so it's really nice easy way for
developers get youtube videos from
YouTube channels direct into the
application so kind of side steps a lot
in the media player and you literally
just plug it in give it you are L and
they're just up there YouTube stuff and
so that's what we're using the i/o app
so it can do live streaming closed
captions all sorts of all those kind of
good stuff that's not GD specific words
on all Android and I believe yet the
library should be available so it should
work on all the Android cool stuff it's
really nice but again that's only a beta
release with playing around with it
YouTube have fun this weekend to be cool
to see what guys come up with that came
out with some new streaming protocols so
basically we've kind of this is GT be
specific but basically we've opened up a
load of the media player stuff so then
you can do custom codecs as well as a
whole load of DRM and other codecs which
are slightly more kind of houston main
streaming video and stuff so it's things
like wide line is now supported things
in the android platform aren't supported
at the moment and at the moment we have
kind of hoping eventually or get over to
Andrew it there's kind of talks but
again it's kind of all those things
where we just it is that she talking
about watch out how we can make it
happen in running at full speed skate
working the gtv in the work-energy back
right yeah exactly and yet obviously
we've got all the new devices that come
out the physio was empty amazing over in
the u.s. little $99 box really really
cool and then obviously Sony releasing
their new box set which is going to be
released all over Europe to yes exciting
time specific there nothing much in
Europe right let's just hang out yep
hence the reason why then so yeah
hopefully I'll get to a point where we
can start doing some goober TV events
all around Europe so again it's
let's get that going good morning going
so good questions have come in from you
hani from Android UI and stuff he asked
why would you ever use max SDK version
in your manifest because he's somehow
managed to get jelly bean on his Galaxy
Nexus and lots of upsetting to be
available so I could people of exactly
one use case of using max SDK which is
if you want to stop supporting a very
old version platform to say you know you
don't want to support users on declare
any more something like that you might
you know use multi APK then use the max
SDK to lop off a version which are no
longer going to actively develop and it
just habit and available through the
multi APK feature and then continue
active determine onwards and see that's
the only could use case i can think of
you both over and use max SDK not an ass
down the other day also don't use much
max SDK yeah please so we rather people
don't give max SDK props and that they
just use the latest SDK to test their
application to make sure they work the
most partner will without any issues
also for the multiple apk stuff that we
use the latest APK that supports that
api version anywhere to be using min SDK
on the newer versions i guess we'll that
automatically in any cap well i can
think of this when you work for
something where the api's have had a
major overhaul between different
versions but other planets have one
major overhaul son likely to have a
level so the globe acts api's like it is
under that but yeah it's depending on
how scared we really want to be
basically so yeah it's just annoying who
sings it yeah we'll take asian yet
thinking that don't use maxi and don't
use matches hahaha its back okay Jan
yeah suzhou have my differentiate the
nexus 7 screen with a normal tablet
tennage i use layout large but i need
different layout to nexus 7 layout dash
S 3600 DP yeah so the shortest width
layout buckets are the ones to go for
instead of using layout large you can
lay out SW
600 would be for this and then SW back
to the purple p for the 10 inches I ask
you about SW a hundred hey hey I'll
Jesus to lose him 20 love them yeah I'm
doing some twenties well there are some
720 devices LG have won this ocean comes
the point yet really from and amber 3.2
onwards you don't really want to be
using the size buckets anymore they're
just not granular enough for this
antarctic you want to be looking at the
DP beds and fathers and your harness
just joined us live in the Hangout as
well oh yeah hey that's going up good to
see it your home unite England yep I'm
in England tomorrow right so do you have
anything you wanted to talk about
specifically did you catch what we were
just saying whilst you're joining the
Hangout I am looking at the no I just
it's good to have you wanna think it's
the first time we've had you in into the
Hangout life I've been the sitting on
the couch right here okay I wasn't here
for the one you're on the couch I must
have missed it also for Jan asking about
how to differentiate nexus 7 if you are
looking to target the nexus 7 i just did
a quick summary and lots of ways to
target it and optimize your application
for nexus 7 so if you check out my
public stream on just + Nick butcher
then you should see a bunch of handy
tips optimizing wrap the necessary so
you're highly say you manage to get
jelly bean running on your phone what
are your impressions I'm not last out
that's big steering magic I mean it's
amazing there goes really really it's
amazing it's still the same phone
company same hardware is what it would
have been so impressive it was for a new
phone method 3 feels like a new phone
but it's the same phone i've been using
for ages
what said basically the smoothness and
sponsors investment yeah I like the new
graphics is up to the notification is
amazing I think that's the best
improvement of helping guys ways the
apps to all implement the new
notifications you haven't played with
the rich notifications system yet you
know I encourage you to watch the what's
new in Android session which is hosted
by Ramon and check the features Daniel
Sandler who was the feeling up on that
and that future and their amazing once
you get used to using them like you know
that do you know that for example it's
all of a sudden so much more useful you
don't have to contact switch all the
time you can just drive down
notifications you know see who all the
latest messages are maybe you need to
dive into inbox respond to them and just
like my advice and once you get used to
working that way it makes me want every
single app so how these fiction
occasions so I highly encourage you to
take a look at that each other I take a
look at the cheeks on but expansion of
the library yes so Jake year Jake
Wharton has been a compatibility layer
to help me do that and i'm pretty sure
that it's actually coming to the support
library at some point I just don't know
one that's in a lot land so until then
jake has done us a favor yet again okay
what did anyone think of the Nexus Q I
mean so far then we limited in its
capabilities but what I'm really excited
about it as you know having this
persistently 250 only announced I'm all
you'd seen lots of developers hacking it
but you know that was kindly intended
behavior so I'm really excited to see
what that product had rows into really
but what do you guys think about it yeah
and I think it's fantastic little thing
yeah I mean if I it's beautiful that's
standin up but yeah it's an interesting
kind of device the whole idea of social
sharing content it's so that's really
nice I think he's been executed
perfectly to be honest well yeah there
are a couple of parties around when we
were in mountain view over the last
couple of weeks while they were very
useful to have these little devices
around just running and play what music
they wanted but as Nick like salad
the best things are yet to come with it
so as people hack it develop some things
for it yeah I'm Leslie I bring expand
I'm sure Alexia is I don't know to make
the ice hopefully at some point so that
will need wraps and stranger and so on
but we'll see how that helped develop
set it up on it Oh interesting process
but indeed where we are building for
Google TV let's see how it fits the the
system all right you can system I think
what's what a lot of work I haven't seen
that if I can have views I hope like a
fancy one but I I think what a lot of
blocks are being missing is the seamless
hell kind of how easy it is to hold of
the thing them to be get used the same
applications you don't have to upset the
application that's very low velocities
there's a giant picture which is hey hey
oh right you get a panic sure so I I
think that something's gonna hear me now
yes my shut up cool so I think what the
block seems to be missing I think this
the seamless integration of a cup that's
the way the the internet work and the
older devices should work together but
you don't have to worry about which
which device you're playing to the each
of the blocks that review just keep
saying that's nearly 50 communities but
it's not the point of the device in my
opinion find us to make it really easy
for you to you have your device you play
your music you walk home you just press
one button that place musically what
interesting but I really am I'm kind of
seeing the how will it work together
with Google TV is going to be the
question for for me and my company yes
what's gonna happen anyways it's going
to be good for me anyways person running
Android and so no matter which one that
way
yes what after television it's not much
we develop a story there right now other
than you know a TV install but and
there's some stuff in the jellybean sdk
like you can look at the media rusev
artists and their media bruta provider I
think she's like a and actually provide
a media action provider i think for
doing things like the youtube app and
the music app does the picking different
and my target to the audio playback in
someone so much that you could stop
reading on the lines yeah let me one of
the things I kind of say listed at the
moment the Nexus Q it's kind of a
product in its own right and it's kind
of targeting that that's social sharing
of content and yeah be interested see
how it evolves especially to the moment
Google TVs is more into their platform
developers to count board with as well
as OEMs to then influent themselves so
yet i'll be interesting to see what
happens because at the moment yeah they
are two completely different products
except for that year those as the
chromebox yeah some people when i'm from
google i/o with the chromebox the google
TV and the nexus q i have to go and buy
a new hdmi switcher just to put them on
it trying to peddle 10 problems first of
all from the experience the TV and then
there's the people who went to the Sadie
google TV party and they got given the
sony google TV as well they were
collecting all the goodies no there's a
lot of giveaways so in the check
agencies a.m. tee time so they also in
purple article in to watch some some
startup companies starting to build a
gaming tube for running android that's
going to be yep third thing in your
living room of course the app streaming
box running mo mag achievements these
days yeah once it's kind of interesting
if you see what games are coming out i
think your guys had a google question
even again yesterday amazing zombies
user like that stuff once on your phone
if you put back on TV it's gonna be
still amazing yeah
yeah Andrew it is android running on the
Nexus Q at the moment you can plug in a
DB and inspected and find out the
version numbers and things there is a
fully functional version of Android on
the next key I think so cam photos from
from out yes DV debugging his nexus team
as he he thought launching he sent a
picture markets the Google Play running
and I study google play store on it yeah
wow I didn't know anyone has done that
yet I thought it would take at least
like four days at the phone in Germany I
saw its on social projector and they had
all these different input devices hooked
up to it so they had a brainwave Seto
Animusic to control of game running on
the queue and then coming out on the
projector which is pretty cool so what
those are the first weekend are so nice
isn't it dual-core especially Galaxy
Nexus yeah yes also audio kye on the
check on it asks how many devices will
spot JB would have come to device tags
so the only ones have been announced so
far are the ones that Google controls so
that's it actually access the nexus s
and the Wi-Fi edition of the motorola
zoo so those the only ones that which we
can hit a button and push over-the-air
updates to other devices of a planet
carrier or again controlled ones you
would happen to us then they followed us
but you know once we ship it with
mickjen I think instead we're going to
be in the 30s getting out that's when we
normally open source codes so you know
but your your arrow EMS and terrorism
and tell them you demanded Andrew Hume
says will project butter take a
noticeable hit on application
computation performance the question
implies that project butter is using
extra cpu to make the UI smoother but I
counter to that it was a process taken
on by the entire android entity to
improve the performance of android by
removing what we were calling jank at
the time and streamlining the OS so I
think it's more that the application
commutation performance will actually
increase because the process is having
to do this to get the three rendering
it's more like being smarter rather than
doing more if you watch the was it for
butter or for worse goes into some debt
describing the processes we went through
so it's not you know some stuff which
we're doing extra work like you know
ramping up the CPU or when touch groups
whatever we're calling it when you went
into sex touch on screen which might you
know have impacted system resources but
only in a positive way really but yeah
it's Regis that being smarter about what
we can we do things and the triple
buffering again may take a look more
memory but actually Bob allow me to use
also on but that's as a Knick point
track you can watch the full bottle or
has take tour food eliason is fantastic
to buy any more before them we can
change what IV now I have been appearing
fast i think probably if you want to
play with jellybeans early Alex you can
grab the sdk for at the previous decays
available via the SDK manager 84.1 and
set up an emulator hopefully you have
hardware emulation support and OpenGL
support on your machine and you can set
up super fast only later which lets you
at least pretend to play with jelly bean
on the Galaxy Nexus a little bit of
things which I'm really excited that was
the templates which got launched as part
of the adt tooling so now we need AC 20
encoded in Eclipse file new project you
have a bunch of different well I need
you to start with but more coming up
different templates so you are you know
you've had a look at these what do you
think of this that was amazing I think
so sir it's going to be one of things
like a two week view hearing bitching
about not tablet applications of this
even the one template there was more
than one template video master of detail
templates it's going to make it so much
easier and the thing is I looked at the
code it generates really easy to start
from the quality usually the code
generation stuff is difficult to guess
once you want to change it he can't do
anything
this is done really well it's really
easy with us get a Stein or the most of
the applications are list and detest
anyways yeah it's not really amazing and
I like be his why binky this time in no
time in Europe yeah it's fun he's done a
lot of work on that also be more
templates coming but yeah this whole
original separate on my brother Leon
Wilson you can now yes as you said in
your post Yanni mind blown I've just
created a multiple fragment app without
writing any code or something it was
yeah just fine now check it is lovely
that was the boilerplate around setting
up a fragment to frame pregnant budget
for was so yeah current caveats it was
it Ice Cream Sandwich plus so and the
goal is to bring that fact somewhat but
that's somewhat tied to our nothin that
we're working on that metal edge of the
action bar listening to tie together
yeah it will come together soon so just
switched back over to the moderator
moderator and a bunch of questions it
appeared on that so let's have a look
through tunnels i'm new to android
development this is PLA from goose creek
i have an app that i want to add
horizontal swipe to move through a list
of orders do i need to move from
activities to fragments and implement
the viewpager so two parts of the
question no you don't need to move to
fragments use the viewpager it works
fine without them but we would very much
recommend moving to preference because
it simplifies the the app layout over
multiple screen sizes in the future
especially if the views inside your view
pager and more complicated but lists are
pretty simple you can as an example that
I knocked up its on google code i'll
post the link to it which lets you have
multiple lists inside of your pager
without any trouble which have a list
adapter with a view pager and then each
one of the lists can be on yeah we met
up works good we got the bonus third
on VLC and android so welcome to level
congratulations on launching and see on
google play a time sometime user PRC on
the desk
and asking can you have multi APK
searching line application avi on the
vice avi yes we've already talked to
individual if there's lots of people
asking for it it's on the road map
hopefully I just don't know as and when
it will ship but it is something we're
looking at so sorry time and again we on
scene direct from flu so currently
undertaking an application with
landscape and portrait orientation is
enabled good I have a video fragment
containing surface view and media pair
when I enable this fragment gc's
occurred with long pause suggestions but
rocks are wooden both you want you
anyone understand that working non pause
so it sounds like there's some sort of
A&R style thing going on to Wendy it
sounds like the garbage collection is
kicking in and then consuming up the UI
thread which it can do on certain chunks
of memory but it's extremely odd the
fabulous I'm assuming it's only
happening when you were changing
orientation it would be good to get some
more information but yeah it quite
something in one long pause as well it
might just be a misuse to one port it
just means the video started to stutter
and pause when the gc's happened yeah I
guess the key things are working with
the media players making sure you're
hooking into all the right like
lifecycle event so you know making sure
that when your activity or one gets
it you know lifecycle callbacks you
doing the right thing for the media
players and making sure you up and
freeing up resources and then recreating
it so yeah without any more information
to like hard to debug this if you have
more informational matters who put that
in we must admit most applications tend
to when they start playing video go into
landscape mode by default mm-hmm I think
just about viewing
I quite like it you tube way of doing it
so they actually handle rotation changes
themselves and despair as the connection
to the handle yeah and then they just
relay out the fragments that it doesn't
actually get destroyed and recreated
they relay out all themselves so the
effect being that the video and it's the
same video of you it's not destroyed and
regretted it is from sighs essentially
animator yeah they just call the
question I oh man I think that's a lot
of aggression change expands yeah
they're great it's nice just jump to the
top okay so he's excited an extra
billion when you change the orientation
as a long voyage the long pause isn't
this garbage collection kicks in i'm
guessing the long pause is the relaying
out at the orientation change its
recreating the views from scratch so if
you do the on configuration change and
listen for well put it in the manifest
to say that you're going to handle
orientation yourself and then call
request layout yourself in the old
configuration change then you should be
able to get rid of that and then it will
work the same way that the YouTube app
does and the video can keep playing was
it moving around because the surface
view isn't being recreated each time and
also it doesn't need to kill the old one
and garbage collected it can just keep
their the current one in memory of that
helps
course you can go back much earlier this
mean okay all right well we're going to
be back the same time next week as
sparkster was asking is a tough top so
the 2 p.m. next wednesday we back on air
to answer more of your questions if you
can put them in the moderator then we
can review them during the week and have
more complete answers for you as well
sorry this was an announcement as a bit
impromptu yeah as you can get there in a
bit of google i/o covering mode after a
couple of weeks of running around with
all there's an exciting announcements
and sessions and but I'm glad that we
can get some people together to chat so
thank you very much for joining us and
thank you honey for coming in life as
well it's talk to you Anna or catch you
all next week play on heading slicing
about your book anyone and anyone who
can make it to London there's a google
TV in youtube hackathon in london and
google campus building you're on Friday
yep something Friday evening through to
Sunday evening there's prizes and yeah
early access to the YouTube a college
talked about earlier it's not much per
second trip I know there's a YouTube is
always somewhere i will post it on the
Google+ page all right at the end of
this thanks very much guys chest is it
like